let me go next to
cooper from texas cooper from texas tell
me what's going on there
holy crap david we're purple you guys
are purple
i know yeah texas is in play that's
amazing yeah you know i'm i'm not very
old but
from my parents and and even my
grandfather and grandmother
never would have thought that texas
would be in the state it's in right now
now i think we want to be realistic you
know it's not
if if biden i think biden does not win
texas in the end but the fact that it's
this close
is incredible and you know what maybe he
will win it'll it'll be a historic
blowout we just don't know yet but
everybody has to vote
um i really wanted to uh ask you to
explain because i remember in your last
video you remarked to some extent that
you said um
you're more for expanding the court now
than you've ever been
yes could you could you expand on that
some more because i'm i'm very on the
fence about
something like that okay so i did a
segment earlier this week on
it which has not yet which is is on
youtube by the time this call goes live
it will be on youtube but you've
obviously not seen it yet
uh one of the main arguments against
expanding the court from the right
is that it's somehow oppressive
undemocratic unconstitutional the
reality is despite
losing the popular vote in six of the
last seven presidential elections
republicans have selected the
overwhelming uh
majority of recent picks to the court
that's not democratic
number two many presidents have added or
reduced
uh seats on the supreme court so it's
not a historical and number three
there's this slippery slope argument
that if biden adds some seats the next
president
will add seats the next president will
add seats the next president will add
seats the reality is you need the white
house the house and the senate to do it
that in itself reduces the opportunity
for it to happen
and i don't believe the public would
accept
expanding the supreme court indefinitely
i believe
in 2021 if joe biden wins and democrats
take the senate
the public will understand the travesty
that has happened over the last four
years
and they will be okay with expanding the
court i don't buy the slippery slope
argument so i am now
very strongly for it okay
and and just one last thing and i'll
give a give up the air time uh
what do you think um the chances are of
another trump electoral victory if if he
were to let's say
cut biden's leads across the board by
like three points something insane like
that
if biden's lead drops by three by
election day
i think trump's shot at an electoral
victory becomes effectively 50 50.
okay yeah all right thank you my
pleasure great to hear from you
uh let's take a quick break uh if you're
holding on to talk to me
don't hang up because we are going right
back to the phones after this short
break
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i
asked teddy stratford to be a sponsor of
the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout